morality is to experience the vein of
awareness which is universal and when we
experience that domain of awareness
which is beyond our personal skin
encapsulated ego identities then we have
the spontaneous understanding of love
compassion it becomes our nature not as
a moral dictate but something which is a
natural expression of ourselves it also
gives us insight into the mechanics of
how intention orchestrates its own
fulfillment spirituality is also a sense
of connection with the creative power of
the universe the mystery that we call
God and by having a sense of connection
to that creative power we gain
self-esteem and have the ability to
create because we align ourselves with
the elements and forces of the creative
universe we begin to realize that the
universe is creative that it's conscious
that it's evolving and our personal
evolution is somehow linked to the
evolution of the mystery that we call
God
classically in India it is taught
through yoga but most people have a
misunderstanding of yoga they equate it
with the physical postures that they do
in a yoga studio which are one component
of yoga but yoga classically is divided
into four types and they have to do with
four basic instincts that human beings
have being feeling thinking and doing so
the yoga of being is meditation self
reflection the ability to shut off the
world of the senses and go to the source
of our own thought
it's called Raja yoga the second Yoga is
the yoga of love through relationship
and understanding that love is is the
ultimate truth at the heart of creation
and that through relationship we can
move progressively from attraction to
infatuation to communion to intimacy to
passion to detachment to ecstasy which
is our ground state the exaltation of
our spirit so love and relationship is
the second means of experiencing
spirituality if somebody doesn't
understand spirituality ask them if
they've ever been in love that's the
experience of spirituality the third way
of understanding yoga or having the
experience of spirit is through service
when you perform service without any
selfish motivation it's called Karma
Yoga then you also get in touch with the
same domain of awareness that we call
spirit and the fourth way of
understanding spirituality is through
the intellect through the mind through
science through understanding how the
laws of nature work because the laws of
nature are in fact the mind of the